hello everyone so this will be a how can
I practice this video and I will be
focusing on three excerpts from
Beethoven sonatas that you all requested
in the previous videos and although
there are specific examples there are
techniques and concepts that can be
applied to other pieces as well and it's
mostly geared towards pianists and if
you're not a pianist maybe stick around
anyway you might gather a tip here or
there but the techniques that I will be
covering will include broken octaves
consecutive chords that are kind of
hopping around in the right hand
contrapuntal sections in terms of
voicing and how to fit rhythmic elements
together and descending trills in the
left hand so stick around if you're
interested if not I'll see you the next
video
[Music]
so the octave pattern your hands can get
tired easily so I would just block it
and then get used to the wrist being
relatively loose for each iteration and
then I would go back and forth between
playing it that way and playing it
I would practice that leap going from
the hind G to the C yes
case in point so this is just something
I came up with to the broken octave
patterns I'm going to be adding these
intervals
[Music]
so in the right hand I would group
certain chords together which was
crucial because just grouping them
simplifies the different positions so
you're not thinking of each quarter note
chord going to the next one so those
might be these two together and then the
next two together and then the next
three together and then again groups of
two and I would spot each of those hand
positions in those groups
[Music]
so in this section one of the trickier
parts in my opinion are actually going
from measure 26 to 27 and then also 30
to 31 because we're coming out of this
broken octave pattern and then we have
to stop on a solid octave and what the
thumb is doing is actually quite quick
so slowly so I noticed this type of
movement gets muddy whenever you're
going from something broken and maybe
oscillating and then stopping on a solid
cord or an octave and that's because of
the quick thumb movement so I would pay
attention to that of course you can
maybe just practice your thumb
[Music]
you
in separating the lines focusing on the
rhythmic characteristic of each line
really helps so first of all the top
line is the one that your ears pick up
the most so we're gonna focus on the
middle line which if this is the beat
that to me is kind of hard to grasp
unless I really pay attention to it in
isolated form in terms of fingering I
would spot the third finger for the
beginning of each measure from 33 34 35
so just being mindful of that helps so
and also the phrasing is short short
long
[Music]
so I would keep that in mind so the alto
voice and then the tenor voice soprano
and tenor Alto and bass soprano and bass
[Music]
so here to keep the hands together and
to keep it rhythmically precise there
are rhythmic markers that I think you
should be more aware of over others so
this is what I'm going to try next
starting from measure 35 I'm going to be
playing the top line of the right hand
with the left hand - the notes on the
beat itself and just the second and
third notes of each beats so that I can
work on the rhythmic clarity of those
two notes
[Music]
so to summarize I think to understand
and hear the rhythm and feel the rhythm
in two parts really helps keep hands
together and also have that rhythmic
clarity and that's combining the notes
on the beat the lines the bass lines
depending on the pitches together with
the up beats
[Music]
so the key here is to pay attention to
the transitions between the trills so
these notes they're descending in the
e-flat major scale
and all the transition notes will be set
of three notes so for example going from
the first and the second trill it will
be these notes and then the next
transition so on and so forth
so Prime your ears to hear those pitches
[Music]
decide whether you want to trill with
fingers one and two or fingers three and
two and make sure you transition over to
those two fingers regardless of what
finger you're using for the first note
of the trill but the fingerings
themselves don't matter as much as those
transitions so when I'm practicing it I
would practice it slow slow and
continuous but with those transition
pitches in mind
[Music]
you want to have that organized because
otherwise you might be doing the trill
ending on the note that's higher and
then restarting the trill below so then
that would there wouldn't be a
transition just as the means of practice
I might go down the e-flat major scale
with this pattern
so just trilling but transitioning from
not two note
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you